[Music]
welcome everybody I hope you can hear as
well I'm really excited to be here today
to talk about how to wear root up trust
with Google cloud IOT core and microchip
r1 are a great partner for a bunch of
security products and other connectivity
products my name is Anthony Paz smart I
lead the Google cloud iit product
management team and I'm with Nicola
Shelley from microchip because one
introduce yourself sure Thank You
Anthony
hello everyone so my name is Nicholas II
I'm managing the marketing and
application engineering team for
microchip and for the script polish
group great thanks Nicola
so today a little bit of an agenda we're
gonna talk about white security matters
for IOT it may be obvious to a lot of
you but definitely something to remind
people we're going to talk about what
whatever would have trust mean really
for IOT devices and that's an important
concept that we're talking about in that
webinar so something really interesting
to to look at we're going to talk about
the difference between hardware and
software security the big debate for IOT
and one of the key point where dressing
in that presentation then well done is
we're going to look at how do I seek or
to get a little bit of an overview of
the new service that we launched fairly
recently something that is currently in
beta and you'd want to learn more about
then we'll look at a secure flow between
Google and microchip which is really key
to the partnership we have together
between the two companies I'm going to
talk a bit about fear more validation
for IT devices is very important if when
you want to make sure what's running on
the device is what it's supposed to be
running and then how do you get started
with all that so without further ado
I'll pass it on to Nicola to talk about
microchip and the security solution that
they have Thank You Anthony so just a
few words so microchip is a four billion
dollar revenue company headquartered
near Phoenix in Chandler Arizona and we
primarily focus on my controller hyper
phones my controller digits in its
signal controllers microprocessors
another single analog interface and c3
solutions also club
timing solutions and obviously wireless
and wired connectivity solutions and
then finally also is compounding flash
memory solutions over all microchip with
the security solutions we've been very
active in the IOT space to try and
simplify how we can secure IT devices
and make that connectivity security
source let's look at why I basically is
that important so if you're looking at
what happened recently they are these
clearly an acceleration of the number of
attacks that are happening in the world
typically targeting IOT devices but not
only overall basically attacks are
breaking becoming more and more
sophisticated and one common thread
among among most of those attacks is the
fact that it's all about the key
material or the confidential material
that are in the devices that is
typically too close to the software so
the software ends up leaking out some of
that critical material so in that
context we work very closely with Google
I'm trying to find out easy but very
secure solution to secure IOT devices so
looking at so that problem basically we
looking at having basically a hardware
boot of trust for connected devices and
what is how the root of trust
so it basically you need to have two
basic concepts so you need to have a
verifiable testable and unique identity
for connected device but you also need
to make sure that which basically allows
you to verify that the device that is
connecting to the service is the one
that she's supposed to be connecting the
second thing is you need to make sure
that you can validate the device
firmware and make sure that what is
running on the device is indeed the
genuine firmware
device intensity it's especially a
little bit like a birth certificate for
each device so it needs to be unique
verifiable and first of all so it's
based on cryptographic key pairs so you
have one product key and a public key
they are mathematically related and you
need to so that the whole identity
hinges on the fact that the private key
remains private during this the whole
lifetime of the product so if the
priority is ever disclosed that means
someone can abuse the identity of that
device and can basically put the the
connection to the remote service so you
need to be able to verify with the
public key that this device certificate
is valid and basically you need to make
sure that overall the private key is
always private during the whole lifetime
of the product so the bottom line is you
have to have a strong isolation of the
product keys from the users you don't
want any of the private keys of any of
the devices to be at any point time
export to any of the users you want to
isolate the public keys from the
software very often as we've seen
earlier the attacks are really about the
weakness in the software leaking out
some of the product keys so the first
point is you want to make sure that
those kids are never exposed during the
manufacturing phase of the connecting
device so overall the best way of
ensuring all that is to make sure that
the any of those keys are never in my
controller that are typically not
designed for hosting sensitive material
the point number three Nikolai's is kind
of interesting because people don't
realize that there is actually a risk of
exposing keys during the manufacturing
process if you're sure leaving your keys
to your manufacturer often time in
countries where no I Telos maybe a
little different it there is definitely
a risk that those manufacturers would
copy those keys and create fake devices
or
a copies of your device's that are not
legitimate and can be used to connect to
your architectures that's something
people don't realize absolutely
especially if you end up generating keys
or generating the identity of those
devices on your manufacture lines so
that may become a very complex problem
and you may need to invest into securing
a manufacturing line in an environment
with secure manufacturing you may not be
that obvious or easy to implement
so looking at how we can implement a
true trustable identity no devices so we
basically are have come up with a
product line of devices that basically
are implementing a few basic features
one is to make sure that you whatever
you saw in the device whether these are
the product is that they are securely
stored in a non-volatile memory so that
memory typically encrypted and you have
also within a cryptographic Hardware
boundary so basically a binary that
prevents someone from looking what is
inside the chip you have also the
cryptographic engines so what you want
to do is you want to have all those
features inside the cryptographic
boundary if any of those features is
outside you security is essentially
potentially compromised because the
cryptographic engine needs to be able to
have access to the private keys to be
able to perform its computation so you
don't want to have to move the party
outside of the cryptographic boundary of
the device similarly you want to be able
to have a high quality random number
generator without any of this you won't
have really true security so for
instance our devices are capable of
generating their own keys and they are
typically the output of the random
number generator so you need to have a
very high quality one under my generator
or if not you would end up being able to
devise keys quite easily that's an
important point here you're saying that
you know the random key generator and
the keys and all that is inside the anti
tempering hardware that means that
that's the hardware you can't open with
like a screwdriver or anything you could
not access what's inside of it but the
private keys never burned into that
device it is generated by the device
itself and it's never outside of it
absolutely so this is a very important
point so the private key is something
that never exists outside of that time
for having Hardware boundaries so
basically we you don't want to generate
your key outside and have to transfer it
inside the safe so the best way to have
a good protection is to make sure that
the
secretly generate within the safe so how
is such device used so basically overall
you have essentially a maximum profit
and on the side of that microcontroller
you would be adding the crypto device
that contains the prodigy cipher key
generated by the device and the main
controller would be generating a
challenge that is changing from time to
time every time you running that
challenge request it's going to be a
different one and that sense that to the
set your elements and then the secure
element uses each pallet key and the
crypto engine to perform the
cryptographic function function and the
output is returned to the Mexican caller
and in my controller them has a response
from the crypto device that is very
tribal so it's actually the my
controller will be able to verify or the
main controller or the remote service
will be able to verify that while it's
talking to has knowledge of the party
and the device basically is like a safe
so the party has been generated inside
the device the device is a secure
element with a cryptographic boundary
that is very protective with many many
layers of security that basically make
the retrieval of the product key
extremely challenging if not impossible
and that device is the ATT a TCC 6:08 a
here it's a fairly small device so if I
record correct
device is available in a couple of
package options so one is an 8 pin
device we're only a few pins are used
but the smallest one is basically a a 2
by 2 millimeters Yuliya allness real ID
so it's something that is very difficult
to spot on any PC because right right so
the bottom line is you want to be able
to have these safe really secure right
so the key is generated in the device
and you want to have
protections that prevent someone from
being able to get the key out of a bus
because again if you if I know the key I
have you identity right so the the whole
identity concept is based on the fact
that the key the party is private and
secret so you have devised a number of
defenses that are implementing in
hardware so you can see on this on this
slide the difference is the obvious
differences you have between a secure
device and in I would say standard
device that doesn't have any other
protection in a standard device you will
be able to see all the logic all the
memory areas that means you would be
able to quite easily with quite standard
equipment to be able to get through the
memory locations and read out the
content so the security man dect
privatizing six to eight devices have as
you can see active shield on top of the
device that basically is the first layer
of protection preventing people from
being able to easily access their logic
that is a mismatch right so now we've
seen we've talked a little bit about you
know the hardware side of things and you
know a very tiny crypto device that can
generate its own keys and random random
key generator sarah and store that very
securely and serve as the crypto engine
let's look at the cloud site now with
Google Cloud IOT when we when we
designed a C platform at Google and we
have a lot experience building IOT
devices you know all of you probably
know the Google home and the glass and
you know some of the Wi-Fi hardware we
have Xterra but there's been a challenge
across every every type of IOT devices
both in in industrial and commercial
world and the consumer wall it's always
the same it's a security challenge
that's what bar dressing today I'm
featuring the device to train the
communication and the identity of those
devices the second problem is scale it's
fairly easy to connect a you know a few
dozens of 2000 devices a few hundred
thousand devices even but when you start
talking about either millions of devices
or millions of messages per second to a
single endpoint this becomes really
difficult to do and this is what the the
experiencing scaling at Google is very
valuable
in that area and finally actionable
insight is very important because
there's really no point connecting
devices if you're not going to get
insights out of that connectivity and
out of the data and that's really a data
challenge a big data challenge at Google
is very very good at we have over seven
products that have over a billion active
users a month so we know our big data I
mean you're probably familiar with
search and Gmail and YouTube and the way
we serve as those kind of challenges of
managing and analyzing very large amount
of data it's one of your core strengths
of Google so we looked at that with
those core strengths and those
challenges and built our IT platform on
that so if we if we look at the product
we just announced with randoms last man
then launched in enough in beta a new
service called cool cloud IOT core
excuse me so classic core is one new
service as part of a suite that creates
our Google Cloud IOT platform it is the
cornerstone of the connectivity and the
device management so well it will
communicate bi-directionally with
devices you'll be able to define your
mat and your devices manage them from
IOT core but then in terms of data flow
the data will flow from IOT core to
pub/sub which is a global messaging
service I'll talk about you can trigger
cloud functions which are server less
processing unit you can trigger data
flows which are the equipment of Apache
beam it's the managed version of the
open source Apache beam which allows you
to do processing over windows of times
for example you know over the last 20
minutes look at all the temperature
coming from those devices and tell me
the the averages and the bands and if I
might out-of-band based on an average
things like that you're doing data flows
very powerful tool all manage for you
and then the data will flow into a
database service like bigquery we are
data warehousing tool or BigTable for no
sequel that those data will be used by
our cloud machine learning engine to
create models at very high speed very
high accuracy and then those models can
be used in data floors and by your
devices themselves and we have some
visualization tool in data studio and
data lab more for your data scientist to
manipulate the data and create better
models overall
so that entire suite is really wet it's
cloud IIT for Google and all the tools
are all of them are managed services
there's really no operations to do with
those so if we look a little bit more
into clarity core there's two components
to it one is the bridge the protocol
bridge which support MQTT and HTTP
protocol endpoints we have a
planet-scale ingestion and a
planet-scale consumption and I'll talk a
little bit about that in the next slide
but that's a very important aspect of
our platform we do automatic load
balancing auto scaling is managed
service fully there's no order scaling
policy to create there's no cluster size
there's no you know no virtual machines
no load balancers none of that
it's an endpoint that you have in your
project and your Google project and we
will scale it up and down to your needs
if during a month you send no data or
very few data you're gonna have a bill
of zero it's really no upfront cost to
using IOT core on the other hand is our
device manager that's where you create
your devices you create all the
attributes you can create hundreds of
attributes on devices this is where
you're gonna have your bi-directional
communication with the device with the
notion of a digital tween and being able
to set States and configuration for the
device you'll be able to have row level
access control which is an extension of
the security of the chip and also of
being able to access all those features
through API is command line and console
similarly so what I was talking about
global scale this is a very important
point for IOT core this is actually a
very big differentiator from other
clouds Google is one of the the only
cloud vendor to have an own and operate
its own back-end globally we own all the
fibers we own the network globally
that's how we serve ads and YouTube that
well because we have the network and
when you create a device and you connect
it to cloud or AG chord you only need to
know one URL it's called mggg the Google
API comm that single URL is used across
the globe to load balanced traffic to
the process access points that Google
has that means that if you have your IOT
core in the u.s. great but your devices
in Australia you don't need to have IOT
core in Australia the device will
automatically connect to the closest pub
in Australia
and use the fibre network to get to the
us to where the data needs to lead that
gives us a scale that nobody can provide
you and that gives us the ability to
pre-configured devices before you know
where they ship you can just say you
know I'm treaty to go go either come on
your device and it will connect
everywhere we connect over port 443
natively or eight eight eight three also
so we support nur we can go through
firewalls pretty easily natively with
IOT course that's a very very big
differentiator when the data lands in in
IOT core I told earlier that it goes to
pub/sub stuff that is also a global
product and means that you don't have to
think about what's that data posted in
Australia or it puts it in India or they
posted in Europe you don't need to think
about that you'll just get the data out
of pub/sub through a single topic and
get all that over several you configure
and you'll get all that data in your
back-end for your application to be
built on so that that scale that we have
know very similarly there's really
nothing to configure for you is
something that's very differentiator
differentiating from other vendors in
terms of authentication because we're
talking about security and identity here
this is an important area so here's how
we do the authentication with Google
Cloud IOT core the device will establish
a TLS session with a Google front-end
anywhere one of those 100-plus
pops and then we'll as that we'll do an
mg T G connect in that in 50 G connect
you have a username that is ignore we
don't use it and you have a password
that password is a simple job token a
very common common concept for web
developers that Java can you sign with
the private key of the device
all right the private key of the designs
it is sent as the password there is no
mutual loss in the TLS stack right it
just sent as the password on the
receiving end of IOT core we take that
dot we validate with a public key
corresponding to that device that were
sending the data was validating the
signature and that mutual authentication
is established at that point so we don't
depend on the TLS stack to do the mutual
authentication that's a very important
point because all we need on the device
is a private key that's it
no certificate no big TLS stack no
dependency of the
pls type to the crypto hardware like the
microchip one you don't need to have a
special TLS back for that if you do an
update of your TLS tag it will still
work you don't have dependency in your
code on that tier that's a very
important differentiator as well allows
to have a much smaller footprint on the
devices to establish quickly a secure
communication while keeps keeping the
while keeping the mutual authentication
via the signature of the job token so
this is a very important point how we
have worked on a few different
implementations on outside and we've
been able to have a Google shadow AC
chord fortification running on the small
a beet AVR follow alright yeah that a
big thing it was very impressive because
I would I would never have never seen it
before because all the stack is so small
it can actually live in the Wi-Fi module
for example entirely in the Wi-Fi mother
was very little memory on a stack so
yeah I pretty simple to implement and
then next to that you can have an 8-bit
MCU that is extremely cheap to read in
your read a temperature or set a few a
few settings in the machine you don't
need a 32 B and C you can just use an
8-bit MCU and and that makes the whole
device much cheaper so this is a more of
a visual representation of that
authentication in a typical flow a
provision or a person will create cheese
a public key goes to IOT core in the
device manager a private key goes on the
device then the device generates the job
finds it sends it as part of the connect
as the password IIT court looks at it
validates the signature and opens the
connection that's typical but you see
the flaw here the provisioner has to
create the keys and that private key
leaving in the provisioners hand has to
be burned on the device so that's where
the partnership with microchip comes
into play the partnership with microchip
is much more secure because if you buy
that crypto chip from microchip because
the crypto chip creates its own private
key inside of it it will generate
corresponding public key when you pass
the picture element to the device it's
already programmed it's not it's not in
a file it's not anywhere in the hands of
anybody it is inside the chip that chip
is put on the device the public key goes
to the provisioner and is sent to the
device manager to be registered then
there's the rest of the process of very
similar
the device creates a dock token the just
open is signed by the crypto device the
SEC 608 natively there's no private key
floating around it's done inside the the
physics and that sign jaw is passed as
the password for establishing the
communication so as you see not model
the key is never ever exposed neither to
the provisioner neither to the device
deployed inside that the very secure
element and it makes it very easy to
connect
so in that context many developers of
connected devices may want to have their
devices up as part of an ecosystem that
is managed so the way the way to do this
is to have a public infrastructure so
luckily Google clouds
Isaac Oh has the ability to well you
have the ability to load your own
certificate authority into the into the
cloud so we can assume that the specific
authority that is managing is actually
the whole ecosystem of devices has done
a good job of protecting the private key
that comes with this certificate
authority so they are responsible for
holding that part keep private
yeah and that certificate authority key
is on a per registry setting so we have
per project you can create several
registries so each registry can have a
CA authority that's different or similar
so you can use the things here in
different registry if you want totally
totally visible as well so the product
key of the CA is at the CA and that's
what you're using a CA is because they
are selling the service of probably
protecting that private key and then you
typically have a gr key of C a so you
have typically intermediate ski
Authority that is below that's rude CA
so it is a signature in the in between
the two thing is very often what we see
in actual deployments people tend to do
this on their manufacturing line and
that's a big part because the whole
trust in the chain depends on this
second private key being private all the
time because if someone has access to
that private key it would be able to
sign certificates of the devices right
and then basically the last level is
that you have the device certificate and
the private key of the device that is in
the device in the secure element and the
statement basically is the one I had
generate that last private key so that
last private key is essentially secure
for the whole duration of the whole
lifetime of the power so overall you see
this chain of trust may have a weakness
if the second key of the immune
certificate authority is not correctly
stored in
in a secure supply chain that's
typically in the manufacturing typically
what we see very often done right that's
a that's a shortcut that you may do when
you're implementing your your
manufacturing life so at microchip we
basically worked on trying to offer a
solution that is very secure for the
customers without having to even think
about how to set up their manufacturing
line so this second key which is the
intimate certificate authority is
something that we offer we offer the
surface of hosting the client intimacy a
product key and essentially signing the
individual devices as part of our
standard man tracfone pro so you don't
have to invest into a secure
manufacturing flow on your side you can
buy anybody directly from us that are
signed by a chain that is completely
trust of all so let's book so the
customer does not need a PKI at all
microchip provides that entire
infrastructure with a secure
manufacturing line that's audited that
has all the certification can be audited
by customers potentially and that means
that when the customer basically just
buys that crypto chip it's all done for
them there's nothing to manage correct
at all they buy it a crypto that they
already programmed already compatible
with IOT core there's nothing to do for
them great so any second intermediate
certificate of HC key priority is told
in our hardware security modules that
are on our secure manufacturing line so
this is something that if you had to
deploy that yourself in your
manufacturing environment is complex you
need to have the expertise you need to
invest into the hardware which is
obviously not free and operate this
while we have that whole infrastructure
ready to go and we doing this in high
volume today it's not about just the
hardware here it's about access from
people who operate in the manufacturing
line the background checks the secure
it's mostly about these patches right on
how you operate that how you design it
to make it secure during the lifetime of
the matrix now the thing is if you
invest into that infrastructure in your
back-end you basically don't going to be
doing this invest investment one so now
if you want to change the price you're
going to have to move all of that or
reinvest so it's quite expected
so initially we talked about the fact
that you have to have to contest so we
spent quite some time on the unique
identity that needs to be truthful in
very tribal but there's a second concept
that is very important to IOT devices
you need to have the ability to verify
that the firmware that is running on a
my controller is valid so you have
basically for this you need to have a
cryptographic key pair for the final
validation one which I mean again the
private key that will be used to sign
the application image so the application
image that you want to run on my
controller will first be hashed and that
gives you a firmer digest and you will
be signing that digest with a with the
private key that is the device
manufacturer public key and that's the
resulting signature is something that is
appended to the application image so
this is another use of the ECC six so it
so correctly the first the first one was
to store the keys to a fancy Kate to
Google karate core it is with the same
chip you can actually do your firm or
validation correct so so basically you
need to have those two concepts
implementing your IT device if you want
to have a secure device so this is the
this is the process to sign your
firmware but what is important is that
at one time you actually by date the
firmware so at one time you have your
host my controller with the application
image and you have the secure element
the HT ECC 608 a on the side that
actually contains the public key of the
signing priority and the host my
controller will compute the digest of
the application image will send that
digest to the AEC c6 or a a which will
be able to verify that that that digest
quest comes to the signature with its
public key and then we authorize or
reject the execution of that of that
application image so then the secure
boot loader
which is the piece of code that runs
under my control that
the start of the the overall firmware of
the product will based on the assistance
of the 608 a will be able to decide
whether the the the firmware should be
running enough now the important point
is that in the six to eight eight
detects that the firmware that has been
verified is not valid it will is
actually locked down it will pop with
the usage of the private key that is
used to authenticate to Google so that
means if the firmware is that is
presented to the 608 a is not valid
the device will refuse to generate a
valid
socket okay so you won't you would you
will essentially be offline you're not
only predicting the preventing the image
from loading but you're also preventing
the use of that key to even connect to
your your court which is a second layer
of security yes so the summary may be on
--then you can talk a little bit from
your site what we've been able to
provide together yeah that's what this
was know several months of work with
microchip and we're really really happy
about the results because it's it's very
much solving a big problem it's today
having a pic of DKI for your for your
devices is not really does not really
make sense having to generate
certificates a lot of customers talk to
us and say how do i generate that where
do I store them how do I mean it's a
pain it's a pain and I think that's
partnership with Google and microchip
really solve all that pain because all
you have to do is literally buy it
crypto from microchip and it's all
configured all able to find a job you
will secure the job validate your
firmware do a lot of the security things
that you have to do on devices but also
in a very very tiny tiny device and I
want to emphasize that this is not in
terms of cost this is not something
that's gonna add dollars to your to your
implementation I mean you want to
comment a little bit yeah so basically
um if you're buying just one device is
basically less than the 80 cells or if
you if you go into like 5,000 devices
you below sixty cents so it's very
affordable so if you think about sixty
cents you know
vol 60 cents per device to avoid having
a PKI
of a complete PK I avoid having to open
to being the news as one of the device
that hacking are doing DDoS attack on on
the DNS servers in the internet that's
actually a fairly fairly low price and
it's such a small footprint that you can
literally add it to almost any design
you can always find space on your PCB to
add this on the side of my controller so
that the level security provided by
their partnership is very exciting it's
the simplicity is amazing really and it
can really work with any microcontroller
processor especially because the IHC
core identification is not dependent on
the TLS tag that runs on those on those
microcontroller that makes it very easy
to be compatible with any any device as
long as you can have an mqtt stack or an
HTTP stack we can have a simple TLS
stack just to connect to Google and the
ability to create a job that's about
what you need on the device very very
tiny we're really excited about this
this solution today I know it is it is
available it is it is available today
and we do have tools to get started very
easily so we have a number of hardware
boards that you can purchase today from
the microchip website and we have here
link that will be available in a
presentation once at the end of this
webinar you can go to this page and you
will be able to buy the hardware and
it's basically a basic maximum color
along with a Wi-Fi device and the secure
element is EC six or eight a that you
can plug together in in a very simple
way and we have all the source code that
we talked about on github so everything
is referenced on on that webpage so you
can download the firmware you can modify
it to your needs and we have even some
examples on how to control a fan or
temperature sensor so we have more
advanced examples and rather than just
the connectivity excellent so those are
very readily available to buy in IOT
core if you sign up for a Google cloud
platform account IOT core has a free
tier so you can I see quarries that are
charged on the bandwidth
only there's no notion of number of
devices or number of messages doesn't
really matter it's a matter of bandwidth
how much data are you sending or
receiving from that mqtt bridge and
there's a free tier of 250 megabyte per
month that you can just use for free to
get your first device is connected and
tested and after that it's a fairly no
downward so in terms of price as you go
up in volume of data so a very
competitive pricing overall only based
on volume of data not on number of
devices not on number of messages
generated so you can get started as two
links here so does google.com slash IOT
you'll land on the extra Atif page
you'll be able to have access to the
documentation some temple codes in
almost many of the common languages on
the microchip side microchip comm slash
eighty ECC 608 a GCT IOT core here
you'll find the devices Nicola was
talking about your fine sample code as
well it's a it's a very easy to get
started and we thank you very much for
your attention and participating that
webinar we have a few questions now so
we'll all go we'll go to that one of the
first question is what is the level of
fit offered that's that's for you I
think yes
so basically tips we have so tips it's
not that field certified device but you
have a number of things they can do
around tips you can have a cat pee
certification for your algorithms which
is something that we do for the six to
eight a that's one thing and the second
thing is you want to have a fit capable
random number generator which is so also
something that we have in that device so
we have the SIP space random number
generator that is incremented and we
have also the newer specification for
the health test so that means the device
will be verifying that the randomness of
the number that is being generated is at
the right level at the time of
generation because you could have
a very good entropy for you random
number generator in your lab but that
doesn't say anything about what's going
to happen in the device once you are in
the field different temperature
different voltage so these are things
that are addressed by the health test
that is implemented in the device so
this is a new standard from v that if
actually tells you how to do is random
number generator and we have incoming
that in the six late a great great also
in addition to this we are we have been
working on the penetration testing with
third-party labs that gives you is
actually a gel level so that you can get
an evaluation on how robust you are
against known the tax and we've been
working with a lab in in europe that is
really typically working on coming to
achieve certification and the deal level
evaluation is something that is
typically the one of the first tests of
the company recertification so the
combination of the tips compliancy for
the algorithms the random number
generator and the proof that you know
the penetration resistance is very high
is something that we can provide to the
interested customers if they really want
to look into this great a so a second
question is around are we going to be
able to provide the presentation or
provide the recorded version of the
webinar i I believe this is recorded and
will be available I'm not mistaken so I
think the answer is yes to that question
can the JWT token be copied and used in
replay attack does the IOT node before
the RTC to provide a timestamp element
so so you don't even often see but you
need time yes so the token is valid for
soon amount of time and you need to have
time at this point so you're gonna get
time from an NTP client for instance and
so the job token is is money to fund has
a creation date and expiration date and
on the Google cloud platform side they
will be accepting targets that are
within that time frame this is a policy
based thing yeah so to to to clarify so
when you create your job you
can specify an expiration correct so
first you can see my job will be only
valued for in 20 minutes or 10 minutes
or whatever
the upper bound of that is 24 hours and
there's a little bit of a I think
there's a few minute lag like window
around that so no more than 24 hours the
job but if you specify in your job that
it's a 20 minute 30 minute to our
validity then you know this is uh this
is what the job can be used for in terms
of period but remember you need to you
need to sign that job with the private
key so it's not only copying the job you
need to have access to the private key
to sign it otherwise you won't be able
to use that job right so you don't need
a not be seeing hardware because you
typically connected so you are able to
get time so that means the other
question here is it is possible to do
similar device update and then update
the ATCC 608 a with a new hash picture
book yeah yes so that's an important
point so indeed the 608 hey are the few
features that allow you to handle this
use case of OTA so basically the six
join a will the first time you're going
to be using it will receive the hash
from the mic controller and then will
receive the signatures that were
generated by the private key at the time
of signing the firmware you receive
those two will violate that they are
valid if they are valid it will throw
them both right and now if you're coming
up with a new firmware it will be a new
signature so you're going to be passing
the new digest with the new signature
and then the device is able to eat again
they match they verify correctly with
the public key will update its content
with the new signature and your new
digest it's quite a lot a question
around or TA and somebody says here ot
are generally poorly verified today can
I use the 35 and 608 to verify the OTA
490 device is connected to high score
yeah that's exactly so there's actually
a is an upgrade from a product that
we've been shipping very large volume up
to quite recently so we launched the six
eight eight in November last year before
that we've been sending the we've been
selling the fiber at a in quite light
loud volume but the six to eight a is
really
and improvement on the number of things
especially the firmware validation to
make it simpler to be able to correctly
support those out here use cases also
the improvement on the random number
generator because again now pips has a
way they have signed eyes the way of
verifying that the random number is good
enough at runtime so we have implemented
this one other question is the
integration effort of the root of trust
with a secure boot loader hi no overall
so we have a few examples on our website
on how to implement secure boot so what
the scheme address presented we have a
few examples on our website that give
you again used example codes on how to
do this so the implementation is quite
simple so the bootloader portion of the
code needs to exist right obviously the
bootloader is communication dependent so
it's something that could be depending
on how you're receiving the new image so
that's something that you cannot we
cannot really provide examples for all
the use cases because they are all
dependent assuming that you have a way
of getting your new firmware into the
device then the 6008 a can be used to
validate the phone call the questions
are flowing for answer all of them does
microchip also have application examples
using pic and views so all the examples
we have on the website right now are
they using ARM based M views but we do
have we have customers using pic devices
so we we have all our libraries that can
write work on pic devices as well
alright that's that's awesome
we're being thanks for the webinar so
thank you for the person who posted that
he's asking about a real estate use
agent would you have a chip in the
building or the wall and other
collection of information on the state
of that building I mean building a
building use cases just so you know we
have hundreds of building that Google
they're very very connect
it and we're actually implementing IOT
core to connect all of those right now
and we're looking at no usage of that
crypto wherever possible but the goal of
the crypto is really to be used on on
each device if possible if those device
are IP enabled if they're not IT enables
you could have those crypto at the
gateway level as well for the for the
building if you have that you actually
have a back net in your building you may
have some devices that won't really be
able to use the crypto that
authentication can be done to a gateway
that uses the crypto device abuse II so
but so yeah a lot of example we have a
great by the way a partner for buildings
called candy control they run around the
connected IOT core they have a great
partnership with Google so if you have
implementations for smart buildings look
at those guys candy control C n di they
have great solution for smart buildings
can be ECC 508 also be used for Google
cloud services absolutely so the 508 a
that as I mentioned has been in
production for many years the 608 a is
an improvement over that in terms of
making the secure boot validation with
the firmware validation simpler and be
able to handle easily d-o-t a use case
so the fiber is a can do very much the
same thing so we can hold the private
key that is used for signing this job
token in the 508 a very similar to the
608 a correct and does Clara and he
Google Cloud IMT support ipv6 so that's
a very good question because not every
plug providers support that so remember
when I told you about the Google network
that we're using this is one of the cool
stuff about building products at Google
we build it on an infrastructure that's
so so big and battle-tested and has so
many features that we just get those for
free the Google front end supports ipv6
so IOT core supports ipv6 that's one of
one of the GD so you can connect with an
ipv6 protocol to the Google front end
and then from there you're on our
network you're in IOT core no problem
there so ipv6 is supported by
energy core is IOT core I I asked for
path and how would you describe it so I
integrated a fully managed service
that's not an infrastructure service
it's almost almost disaster she talked
about it
it's an endpoint so when you log into
your de city console you'll see at the
bottom left there's there's gonna be a
link called IOT core you'll go in there
the first thing you do is you create a
registry and you give it a name and
inside that ready to recreate a device
and upload your public key that's all
you have to do and that's it there's no
no configuration nothing then you have
MQTT Google API SOCOM that's your import
as I said it's a global endpoint you
know I have to think about where you are
you have to think about the fact that
you're in Australia in the US or in
Europe in Japan doesn't matter we'll
load balance to the closest Google's
front end and get that traffic to the
region where you want it to be so
there's one region globally that you
used to have your device manager but the
connectivity is global the data island
into the region you choose so a fully
fully managed service no load balancing
policy nothing no auto scaling policy no
cluster no shards none of that no VM
nothing no updates everything is done
for you to fully manage service how
cloud is Ecore help the global
corporation to scale as the number of
IOT connected devices can vary
tremendously across the globe I really
that's that was it so one of our core
strengths there's two things first it's
a managed service by Google so we we
will manage the scaling up and down for
you you don't have to you'll have to
think about it you can send us 10
million device to 20 million device it
doesn't really matter to us that's that
you don't have to think about it that's
our job to do and Google does that
really well and you know just look at
YouTube and Gmail and all those other
services and search and as distribution
all that are super scalable that's why
we use to power IOT core the other thing
is you're talking about global scale the
cool thing about the global network we
have is because when you use them to TT
to Google API comm it is globally
distributed if you have a network of
devices that is globally distributed you
will actually be automatically load
balanced across
hundred-plus front end that we have
across the globe so you're not hitting
the same front end by all your millions
of devices across the globe there will
be automatically automatically
distributed which helps a lot with the
distribution of loads across the globe
so we're really well architected to do
exactly that the big global corporation
at scale and I think that's all we have
question that was quite a quite a quite
a good number here please provide
feedback on on the webinar there's a way
to do that through the tool we'd love to
hear what you liked what was missing
what you didn't like would be happy to
do another one later on and as we have
updates on IOT core web updates on the
ECC 608 and different implementations so
happy to talk more about this I think
this is really changing the game in
terms of security and IOT it brings
simplicity to our customers while
keeping the level of security at the
highest possible but removes all the
hard old and works perfectly with our
cheek or so really exciting about this
and if we don't have more question I
think we'll end a tiny bit early Thank
You Nicola for being well thank you for
giving us the opportunity of talking
about that great solution it's a
pleasure thank you very much and thanks
everybody
oh one more question is there any common
criteria like evaluation certification
plans for 80 DCC 608 so as I mentioned
we are doing so we would not planning on
certifying the device for common cataria
however we're doing penetration testing
for the 608 a which is one step that is
typically early in the process of doing
coming to their certification so we can
share the results of that penetration
testing with customers in the NDA
whenever they actually have a you know
they want they have interesting that in
that question and that will prove to you
that basically the key that is inside
your device is correctly protected for
the lifetime of the of the pollak great
and somebody's asking for a clickable
link so I'm gonna try to see if I can
post that in in the chat that me and we
do that
CCC 608 a DCP I gotta call my god TCC
hey GCP damn I'm fat fingers here
all right about that g CP IOT core okay
by loading a cpt core you verify that
I'm here I'll post it in the chat a gtp
int quarter okay we're here so let me so
how do I share this here is there a Chat
Chat Chat Chat Chat presentation that
working for everybody you know I just
have a problem with the chat so that
censored from oh here we go okay cool or
we're at the end of it thank you very
much great audience actually that was
quite a lot of people watching that's
cool and we hope this will give you idea
then more importantly we hope you'll
secure your next - hi looking forward to
talking to some of you so thank you very
much thank you for a great day bye